إنه السادس من نوفمبر 1814 في
مدينة دي نانت البلجيكية ومنزل متواضع
بُني في شارع سيحمل اسمه لاحقًا
، ولد أدولف ساكس بعد 28 عامًا
بينما كان يعيش في باريس ساكس ،
اخترع الساكسفون وأحدث ثورة
في الموسيقى بطرق لم يستطع.  تخيل ولكن هذه
ليست هذه القصة ، فهذه هي قصة
كيف نجا ساكسفون قوي من الموت سبع
مرات قبل أن يصلح
الساكسفون بالكاد يبلغ من العمر ما يكفي للوقوف.
ابتلع قدرًا كافيًا من
الماء أسفل حامض الكبريتيك
ظنًا أنه حليب بعد سنوات ،
ووجدوا نفسه قريبًا جدًا من
انفجار البارود ، وقد تعرض للحرق مرة أخرى
عندما سقطت مقلاة من الحديد الزهر
أسفله لاحقًا سقط حجر سقف على
رأسه
ترك ندبة تدوم مدى الحياة صعبة بمجرد أن
يختنق ، وعندما
تُركت أشياء ملوّنة مؤخرًا في غرفة نومه
طوال الليل ، استيقظ بالكاد وهو يلعب مع
الأصدقاء في نهر مجاور.
تيار سريع وكاد
يغرق مرة أخرى ، نجا من
الموت [موسيقى] في السابع من فبراير 1894 ، توفي ما يكفي
بسلام في باريس ، كان الساكسفون قد
عبر بالفعل المحيط الأطلسي مهيأًا
للتطور إلى أيقونة لموسيقى الجاز الأمريكية
ويضمن خلود الساكسفون
[موسيقى]